You bought your first crypto.
You can see the balance on the screen.
But who is actually holding it?
Because on most platforms,
the answer is not you.
Stay to the end
and you will know which of the two kinds
you are using,
and the one thing to do
the moment a trade settles.
Start with the number
that surprises people most.
Zero.
That is how many private keys you hold
when your coins sit
on a centralized exchange.
The company holds every one of them.
So what is an exchange, actually?
An exchange is a marketplace.
Nothing more mysterious than that.
It matches somebody who wants to buy
with somebody who wants to sell,
and takes a small cut
for standing in the middle.
It is also where the price comes from,
and where liquidity lives.
Liquidity just means
there are enough buyers and sellers
that your order fills
at roughly the price you expected.
But how that middle is built
is where the two families split.
One of them is a company.
The other is a piece of code.
And that single difference
decides everything else about them.
A company, or a smart contract?
A centralized exchange is a business.
Coinbase.
Binance.
Crypto.com.
It runs an order book,
it checks who you are,
and it keeps your coins
in wallets that it controls.
A decentralized exchange
has no company in it at all.
You connect your own wallet,
a smart contract does the swap,
and your keys never leave your hands.
Most of them do not even run an order book.
You trade against a pool of coins
that other users put there,
and those users take the fees.
So look at what each one
actually hands you.
Centralized.
Deep liquidity and fast fills.
Cash in, and cash out.
It holds your keys.
Decentralized.
You keep your keys.
No identity check.
Thinner markets, and network fees.
Neither column is the winner.
They are answers
to two different questions.
What is a trading pair?
One thing confuses every beginner,
and it is written on every screen.
You will see it written as BTC / USD.
The first one is what you are buying.
The second is what you are paying with.
That is the whole idea.
A price only means something
measured against something else.
And they come in three kinds.
Crypto against real money.
Crypto against other crypto.
Crypto against a stablecoin.
Which pairs a platform offers
decides what you can buy directly,
and what costs you three trades
and three sets of fees.
Not your keys, not your coins
Now the part that catches people out.
The friendlier platform
is the one where you own nothing.
A centralized exchange feels safe.
There is a support line.
There is a password reset.
It looks like online banking.
But those are exactly the features
that require somebody else
to be holding the keys.
Your balance is a row
in that company's database.
The coins behind it sit in their wallets,
pooled with everybody else's.
There is an old line about this
and it has outlasted every exchange
that ignored it.
Not your keys, not your coins.
So do not treat an exchange
like a bank account.
It is a place you pass through.
So how do you choose one?
Before you trust any platform
with a single coin,
run the same five checks.
Two-factor authentication from an app.
Most coins held offline, in cold storage.
A licence in a country you have heard of.
Fees you can find without hunting.
A history you can look up.
Miss one of those
and you are not choosing an exchange.
You are hoping.
And once you are in,
four habits do most of the work.
Turn the two-factor on first.
Start with an amount you can afford to lose.
Learn limit orders before market orders.
Then move what you are not trading
off the platform.
A limit order waits for your price.
A market order takes whatever is there.
That difference costs beginners
more than the fees do.
So — back to the balance on your screen.
The question was never
which exchange is the best one.
It is: who is holding it right now?
Know that,
and you already know
whether it should still be sitting there.
The full comparison and the platform reviews
are linked below —
and nothing here is financial advice.
If that was useful,
subscribe for more videos like this one.